تعالي اقول لك هذه القصه عن الامير
المنبوذ هاري اصبح من دون حمايه شرطيه في
بريطانيا بقرار قضائي وذلك بعد رفض اقاضي
في لندن قطعنا الذي تقدم به محمد الامير
ضد هذا القرار الحكومي قاضي المحكمه
العليا اعتبر ان الحكومه البريطانيه لم
تتجاوز سلطتها عندما حرمته من توفير
الحمايه له خلال تواجده في المملكه
المتحده الحكومه البريطانيه توقفت عن
توفير حمايه شرطيه للامير هاري وزوجه
ميجان بعد تخليهما عن واجباتهم الملكيه
وانتقالهما الى كاليفورنيا عام 2020
علق انه لا ينبغي ان يسمح الضباط الشرطه
بالعمل كحراس شخصيين للاثرياء هاري من
جهتي اكد انه لا يشعر بالامانه اثناء
زيارته لبريطانيا مع اطفاله الصغار واستند
الى ما يقوم به مصور البابراتسي
اذا الامير هاري كان المجرد هو وزوجته في
الايام الاخيره اعتقد الاسبوع الماضي
لمطارده وكادوا يعملوا حادث يعني يكون
طبعا هو يغمز من هذه القناه وعلى هذا
الاساسي يمكن يطلب الحمايه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات